with 150 yes el Washington
congratulations thank you thank you this
is like real history especially with
Sydney being here tonight on believable
you're the first since 1963 right what's
that doing to your head when I heard
about a Randy Newman I was getting
nervous I was like oh god not 16 times
but what an honor it is just to be first
of all just to be up there on the stage
with him you know that old presentation
he's such as we all know a class
individual and and he's been a friend of
mine for a long time he's given me
advice the first one or two pictures at
I ate he gave me very good advice about
my career and in fact was in an indirect
way responsible for me doing the film
cry freedom because I was actually
offered another film which he suggested
that I would turn down and since I
didn't feel that good about doing it all
those for a lot of good money but I did
turn it down and then got cry freedom
which was the first time I was nominated
so I'm in debt to Sydney so many ways I
just love him this idea of you now being
a part of history
yeah is that I'm 30 because I'm a part
of history because we're busy Bueller
first since 1963 to win for best action
yeah yeah and now the first to have to I
guess yeah
well you know I you know I tell you
really very much like the first time
that I want I was just very calm all day
today and I turn the TV on I was
watching the NCAA finals right up until
4 o'clock my wife was going crazy like
we gotta go I'm like I'm trying to wait
to see who's gonna win
I just felt relaxed you know and and
I've been to the dance a few times and I
knew it was out of my hands and you know
I've done what I could do as an actor
and
I just appreciate the fact that the
Academy recognized me this time but this
being a part of history what's that like
for you I don't know how much that's
even sunk in yet you know I'm already a
part of history you know in a lot of
ways and the whole thing with Sydney and
all that I mean that I'm just glad to
know the man for me it's more personal
you know there's a lot of talk about it
and race and all of those issues but my
feelings for him I've had long before
this became news and and I just feel
closer to him now I mean I am in terms
of awards but just personally I feel
closer to him 150 is it better the
second time around uh you know what I
think it's more exciting or surreal the
first time I was just taking pictures
with Halle Berry and she's she's in the
where she is I know the feeling when I 1
10 11 years ago I ran into Kevin Kline
because I think he had won the year
before and as soon as I went off stage I
was like I just didn't know if I had
actually won or if I just ran up there
and you know it is surreal this time
it's a little I just had a piece about
me all week and all day and I told my
kids win or lose I'm go home and hang
out with them and that's what I'm gonna
do I think you give a new meaning to
black by a popular demand black by
popular well you know what people use
the word movie star and I like to say
I'm I'm hopeful and after who's become
becoming more more popular you know it's
a craft I respect the craft I tried to
do my best work and I'm really pleased
and relieved to see that the Academy is
recognized in people for their work not
just for the amount of money that's
spent on a campaign I think that's a
that's a good thing Denzil hi great are
you good
do you feel that you know one thing
about this performance is that it's a
total change of pace for you as your
roast real villain right
it do you think that gave you an an edge
people working at you as an actor in a
way they'd never seen before
I think so I think you know had I played
another I don't know I don't know
another hero or a real person I think
that playing this role did kind of shot
people a little bit and show them that I
could do other things I didn't
necessarily do it for that reason I mean
you know you didn't do the role to win
the Oscar I don't know come away I
didn't think it was that type of role
and and you know I don't do any role for
that reason certain roles have a certain
you know vibe about them like a Malcolm
X or even the hurricane definitely not
training day but you know turned out
well you've you've also just recently
joined what's called Hollywood's 20
million dollar club congratulations on
that level this year with your first
movie went now that you've won the Oscar
does that get a bump and pay on that
well you know none of us are worth what
we get I mean so I just try to work hard
I don't get bogged down and how much and
who makes more and blah blah blah you
know I've been blessed I've been you
know making good money for a long time
and you know when I started acting in
college I thought I was going to one day
work on Broadway and makes 650 calls a
week and that was good enough for me you
know my intention has always been to
grow as an actor to to get stronger to
get better and as a result I've like I
said I've been recognized by the people
and now being compensated in a way that
I am so I'm blessed number 166 down in
front here hey how you doing
congratulations thank you you know
Sidney Poitier's always talked about how
he's captain his own ship throughout his
career
how would you equate your career with it
do you follow the same guidelines and
he's pretty much called his own shots
since the beginning well I think actors
always have the power which is the power
to say no you know I think I know the
reasons I'm standing here today is for
the rules that I didn't do not so much
for the roles that I've done you know
may sound egotistical or whatever but I
think that we do have control over what
we do and we if you compromise
you will be compromised and I've tried
to you know have a certain level of
integrity and credibility to work that
I've done and you know pays off on
nights like tonight one other quick
question tagging along to that is that
you've always put a lot of effort in
your roles that play that you do a lot
you just seem to study the role you you
spend a lot of time whatever the
character is going to be can you talk
about that a little bit well you know I
feel like I have an obligation to the
public you know I try to work real hard
and they're paying their hard earned
money to come in to be entertained and
and I'm being paid a lot of money to
entertain and even before being paid a
lot of money I just feel that you know
that's what I'm there to do I can't do
things in a in a half-hearted way I try
to work as hard as well as I can and the
audience knows that when come to see me
they'll know that I'm working hard for
them and I'm giving it everything I got
number 118 118 thank you along with this
award comes a big responsibility and yet
you've said I don't want this to be
weighted with a favor I don't want it to
look like you know this just doesn't
isn't about the work isn't about acting
I loved your laugh at your acceptance
speech can you separate the two the
pride in the work and the pride of what
represents well what do you think it
represents a terrific part and maybe an
acknowledgement of a whole body of work
saying it's time we you know this adds
on to the pleasure I've been nominated
five times I've won twice and I think
that that that's you know speaks to I
guess how people feel about my work you
know I take pride in what I do like I
said I work very hard I've been
recognized for it over and over again in
many ways by the public and by the
Academy and you know that's all I do I
don't I don't put too much on you know
I'm not really out there listening to
what everybody's saying and what the
issues are I believe the universal stems
from the specific and my job is to do
the best I can as an actor that's what I
do that's what I concern myself
with how people respond to that that's
on them I can't walk around asking
everybody how they feel about what I'm
doing I won't get anything done that way
did that Lambert 70 speech mean you're
still having fun doing what you know
what I had the most fun tonight I you
know I came in tonight and and before I
came I read a little scripture from the
Bible that talked about just sharing
with others you know that when you're in
a position of opportunity share with
others and and I and I took that to mean
just as you know I don't be so
close-minded and shut down and tight but
just have some fun and talk to people
and and I did you know I want folks
hands in the crowd you know the regular
folks and it's had fun I just felt very
relaxed I still feel relaxed and turned
out well number 236 congratulations
thank you long overdue well what are you
going to do with that Oscar then put it
next to my other one ask the kids we'll
do it by committee tonight and find out
what they what they suggest where they
suggest that you go you know we have
sort of a trophy room in the house I
guess that's where they'll go you've got
a lot of support and to get this award
one of those was Julia Roberts what was
that feeling about well you know I was
getting I was hearing a lot from a lot
of different people I've been getting a
lot of calls and people are like this is
your time the old lady's about dreams
and then they dream about this and that
and everything I've been hearing from a
lot of people and you have to just kind
of sit tight and put a lid on that
because you don't know you know but
obviously the the feelings that people
had that were genuine and and I'm happy
yeah we have time for two more questions
number 66 and then number 111 66 right
oh okay I just dropped my 66 I'm sorry
anyway tomorrow most newspapers in
America are going to make a big deal not
just about the achievements that you and
Hallie have contributed which are of
course considerable but I wonder as an
actor having constantly you know found
yourself nominated five times if you
feel that because so much is going to be
made of the race component that
country has still a race problem or if
it has a race problem masquerading as a
class problem or what your thoughts
ounds like a question for Randy Newman
what about it 16 times what was he blame
what would he say but I like on his 15th
time when he lost is that racism I'm not
suggesting that my question is what is
your question
number 66 what would you like to know
turn it over make it 99
that's the question again go ahead 99 do
do I was no serial that there will be a
time where we will not have headlines
saying black actor wins and and do you
think do you write for newspaper
unfortunately yes and make sure it
doesn't happen tomorrow just say actor
wins that's what a chance you had what
an opportunity yes 111 it's the same
okay a couple years ago we down with you
in Sidney Poitier and for us a yeah the
four seasons and you at the time had a
piece of paper that you had saved over
the years from someone saying that you
were destined for great things
prophecy yeah yeah yeah I don't have it
on me but yes I still have it yeah woman
prophesied that I would speak to preach
to millions of people and you know and
there you were well yeah I guess she was
right yeah no I don't know I don't carry
it on because it's kind of fragile now
and falls apart but I still have it that
was a wonderful day we spent with thank
you very much congratulations